what do you recreate Assisting chapel in  this boy's room not that right  you should be knee-deep in a sofa with  some great as ice whatever he goes I go  whatever you say officer look what's  happening it's hard give me the  defibrillator  [Music]  took my wife dirty cops  where you go I'm gonna kill him  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [ __ ] it it's a video game  Oh [ __ ] grown up man I don't play  video games yeah well maybe you should  try to help you with your aggression  these have we seen I'll do anything for  my family this is just [ __ ] anything  as against but bring him to us and  you'll get your wife back you got an  hour you're going to jail you just say  stupid [ __ ] all the time I'm going to  show you come on with me pal  I want baktun powers and the remans  detail can you get the [ __ ] out of the  caucus I have pepper spray in my first  they ever go to my points  [Music]  you